who do you think you are you don't talk
to me that way you're like an intern
like she actually said that
you talked about wanting to sort of have
one foot out the door and that maybe
that's respected by management they see
you want to do your own thing was that
always the case for you
well
I've gotten fired from an internship
which you gotta I wasn't getting paid so
like interns don't get paid so imagine
how horrible of a job I must have been
doing to get fired from an internship
and this was actually at the time kind
of a traumatic experience for me I was
20 years old and I got an internship at
the MTV beach house in Seaside Heights
New Jersey so imagine you're 20 years
old this isn't like the peak of MTV like
when MTV was MTV and they had this beach
house and I'm gonna intern there so I I
got in an apartment with like five other
interns for the summer
and I'm just thinking this is going to
be the greatest summer of my life and
it was not the greatest summer in my
life but also too I didn't understand
how to be professional like they were
just I was just very
wild you know for lack of a better term
so I remember playing basketball with
the MTV BJs like car and like getting
physical with them like while we were
playing and like and just like the
things I would say so
um
uh there was an incident
there was an incident we were raking I
was lifting part of the stage a band was
there and like a production assistant
was raking sand and she said
uh she was complaining about raking sand
and I made like a smart-ass comment to
her like hey do you want to switch
places and she actually said who do you
think you are you don't talk to me that
way you're like an intern like she
actually said that like I thought only
people talk like that in the movies but
so then she got the head of the interns
to come
and this woman came and said I'm going
to give you five seconds to apologize
and
everybody was watching and I said you
can give me I'm usually don't have cool
things to say like this but I said you
can give me 5 000 seconds to apologize
and it's never happening so publicly I
got fired like in front of everyone it
was humiliating I had to like give him
my line or walk through like a walk of
shame around the beach house and it was
terrible I was like in college and I was
like I can't even make it at the MTV
beach house but there's a lesson in this
every summer up to that point I had
applied for an internship with late
night with Conan O'Brien and didn't get
it so I drove back home to Philadelphia
and I just decided the next morning to
call the internship guy again at Conan
and I said hey look I had this
internship at MTV it didn't work out can
I just come in one day a week because
this was my last summer before senior
year this was my last chance to get to
do an internship and he was like all
right yep just come in on Fridays
so I started coming in on Fridays at
that summer I would drive to New York
from Philadelphia and then then he said
well why don't you come in on Thursdays
and Fridays so then I started coming in
Thursdays and Fridays then I got a call
and said why don't you intern over
winter break and stay here for a month
so
that was really cool it was a good
lesson that sometimes a bad thing can
happen to you and it can lead to
something better and that was an awesome
internship I really thrived there and
had a good time and interesting people
so it worked out in that situation